can you listen in order to listen WA has
to amplify
if the sound is low one its amplified
and this just like in the case of the
DNA if one has a very small amount of
DNA for example even the sickle molecule
one needs to amplify it in order to
sequence and to study the DNA
my most important invention was the use
of the feet went in idna polymerase for
the an amplification it is widely used
in biotechnology and in medicine
when I finish my business thesis I
decided to go to New York with a Nobel
Prize winner several ciao
where I spent three years when we came
back to Spain my husband myself we
started the fee 29 to ever
after a few years my husband that was
very generous and wanted me to be
independent decided to quit the fee 29
work and start a new war by himself so
that I could be independent for the 5:29
world from that time on I just became
moderator solace and not my husband's
wife
and I presented a they work on the
faithful 2019 the polymerase USB asked
me whether I was going to patent the
polymerase and I said yes so they felt
me with the patent the person was very
profitable from the economic point of
view
[Music]
for Miller sets is really a passion I do
not perceive life without research so I
hope to be able to cook it going for
many many years from now
[Music]